and that's the thing is like in 2022  women are bailed out of every single bad  decision that we make like every single  one we are bailed out so um for example  like they used to require women to be  virgins to get a ring we make the  decision to sleep around and we still  get ranks right that's one bad decision  or let's say we get pregnant you can get  bailed out of that bad decision because  you get an abortion or you can keep it  and you can still give it up for  adoption or you can keep it and you can  still get remarried typically where like  historically that you would have been  done for even if you weren't a virgin  like you would be done for